Де-факто Віктора Януковича в його Хонці
немає вже чотири роки
А де-юре - є
Принаймні, народний комендант
Межигір’я інколи отримує повістки
з українських судів, які вважають
Хонку адресою Януковича
Що, в суді невідомо, звідки Янукович дає інтерв’ю?
Будинки в резиденції - заарештовані
Але належать вони і досі компаніям,
пов‘язаним із екс-президентом
Тож час від часу до "народного коменданта Межигір’я" Дениса Тарахкотелика
приходять якісь люди та вимагають
звільнити ці приміщення
"Приходили з ціллю, типу, я тут маю жити
Ви не представляєте… я кажу,
є різні випадки в нас
Денису Тарахкотелику насправді не до жартів
Адже, на його переконання, ключове питання
залишається без конкретної відповіді
так хто є реальним власником Межигір’я?
За документами тут близько 140 гектарів землі.
І три власники
Окрім Януковича, ще дві його компанії
Більша частина фірмі "Танталіт"
І третя частина якоїсь там
офшорної англійської вроді компанії
І всю забрали?
Чи частково забрали?
Куди забрали? Кому повернули?
Найсильніші звинувачення на адресу Януковича
пролунали від Генпрокуратури
після перемоги Майдану
Він та його близьке оточення, за її даними
вкрали в держави різних активів на суму
більше 40 мільярдів доларів
Громадські активісти кажуть
майно в основному досі не конфіскували
і не повернули у власність України
Навіть коли докази лежали на поверхні
як у випадку із цим вертолітним майданчиком Януковича
і бізнес-центром "Парковий" під ним
Нещодавнє розслідування показало
що вже і особливо шансів повернути
цей вертолітний майданчик
в нас не лишилося
Деякі соратники Януковича
домовилися з нинішньою владою,
напевно, за якусь плату, обіцянку, знижку
зберегти свої активи,
закрити кримінальні провадження
Більше того, в України - мало шансів
зберегти навіть ті активи
які нині заарештовані та конфісковані
Експертка переконана, що з часом
доведеться їх віддавати
Не виключено, навіть з відсотками
Адже доказова база щодо злочинності цих активів
занадто слабка
В Україні нема жодного вироку суду
стосовно високопосадовців часів Януковича
стосовно близьких соратників Януковича
який би визнав їх винними в корупції, в організованій злочинності
Лише наприкінці минулого року
почала роботу АРМА
Національне агентство з питань
виявлення, розшуку та управління
активами, одержаними злочинним шляхом
Наразі в її управлінні понад 270 різних об’єктів
пов’язаних з колишніми можновладцями
Квартири, будинки, підприємства, нафтові вежі
навіть аеропорт Одеси
На ситуацію з активами Януковича і Кo
тут дивляться так
Кримінальне впровадження не завжди закінчується якимось вироком
позбавленням прав на певне майно
Можливо, по результату певного тривалого часу
держава буде повертати цей актив
тому наше завдання
зберегти актив в належному стані
Серед успіхів агентства
три поверхи бізнес-центру Гулівер у центрі Києва
Раніше вони мали відношення
до екс-міністра доходів та зборів
Олександра Клименка
Тепер будуть здаватися в оренду
Та такі випадки - радше винятки, ніж правило
кажуть антикорупційні активісти
За їхніми даними,
більшість об’єктів команді Януковича
все ж таки вдалося залишити для себе
І мова йде про мільярди доларів